[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 six seven four seven
once again
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact Philip Stapleton was
exploring a thrift store in the UK when
he came across a painting he likes so
much
he nearly spent $300 on it even though
he and the sellers knew it was just an
imitation after studying the unusual
picture he was inspired to do a little
more research
he took the painting to an auction house
to be examined by an art expert named
Rosie Mae after you very carefully
studying the painting and taking it out
of the frame
she found a message with a very clear
signature from Pablo Picasso one he used
earlier in his career
then with a spyglass he noted that it
had been dedicated to his nephew Xavier
Philip said that he was stunned when he
heard that the painting was probably
authentic and could be worth millions no
one knows exactly how much but back in
May 2015
another Picasso painting fetched more
than one hundred and seventy nine
million dollars in a Christian whatever
the final amount he had made the
purchase of a lifetime friends you know
the Bible says that sometimes a pricey
investment can pay off in a big way
stay with us we're going to learn more
on this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and this is just as it
sounds a libel answer program if you
call in with your questions we will do
the best to answer them phone lines are
open this is a live program and a lots
going on in the world today with
everything from the coronavirus to
earthquakes and we're gonna be talking
about the Word of God phone call if
you'd like to call in with your
questions eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven not only are we on
the satellite radio and a number of
land-based stations we're on the
internet around the world and we're on
Facebook and you can that be the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page or the amazing
facts Facebook page you can watch what's
happening here in the studio as well as
calling your question one more time the
number eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven and I am Doug
Batchelor my name is Jean Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug as we
always do let's start the program with
prayer dear father we thank you that we
do at this time to open up your word and
study together and we ask your blessing
upon us here in the studio and with
those who are listening wherever they
might be at home scattered across this
country and even around the world Lord
that you would guide us into a clear
understanding of your word and that we
would be encouraged and strengthened as
we look at the Bible for we ask this in
Jesus name Amen
amen Oh pastor Doug we opened the
program this evening in rather an
interesting situation it's the 22nd of
March and for those who are listening
we're in California Sacramento the
capital of California and Thursday last
week I believe it was the governor of
California
issued a in sort of order that
everybody's shouting place or stay home
so that's an eight high the house yeah
stay away from large crowds and we can
we just we're talking before the program
the economic impact that this would have
on so many small businesses family-run
businesses is it's unprecedent that's
something like this has ever happened
before and of course we keep hearing
reports about more and more people
getting sick and
death toll seems to increase and just an
amazing time that we find ourselves in
it is yeah and it's you know the the
viruses we're watching the news is
filled with this unfolding around the
world and and we have amazing facts as
missionaries in India I was on the phone
with him last night and they're
basically they're kind of locked down in
the city of Hyderabad they took a
picture outside the way now you and I
have worked in India several times and
it's constant honking of horns and the
streets are just so loud and she took
her phone and put it out the window
giving me a live video feed and said
listen no horns you can hear birds it is
scary we've never heard in the street so
during the day the streets are all
locked down but the letting people come
out to shop in this time of year it's
very hot in that part of India but same
thing with Africa they're beginning to
have cases now in some of these
congested countries that don't have the
medical resources and the world's on
edge they're on edge you know it makes
me think of the book of Job how the
tests that came to Jobe were tests of
wealth and then health and it's like the
world is going to be really tested on
the health front and the wealth front in
the next few years and well you know
maybe at least months but I think the
falling on me out may it last few jobs
challenges came in a very short period
of time and just look at how things have
changed in the last week yeah exactly
exactly but now we're drifting a little
bit our fact was talking about finding
real riches mm-hmm which is this this
man discovered he had bought it was you
know he knew it was a Picasso but they
call a knockoff some artists said I'm
gonna make an imitation Picasso and he's
know that looks pretty good almost looks
like the real thing so he bought it
through store found out on investigation
it was someone he had given to a family
friend that ended up in a thrift store
and it was real and it's worth millions
and he paid $300 now you can imagine if
you own the thrift store you'd be really
kicking yourself there so the family
member that donated the work of art
exactly exactly
but it makes me think of a parable in
the Bible where Jesus said in Matthew 13
again the kingdom of heaven is like a
merchant seeking beautiful pearls who
when he has found a pearl of great price
he goes and sells all that he has that
he might buy it well this man was
thinking well $300 is a lot for a thrift
store painting but he recognized some
value in it and boy was he thankfully
did it but when you find that pearl of
great price that's speaking of Christ
and eternal life the plan of salvation
it's worth selling everything jesus said
if you'd come after me need to be
willing to forsake all and you'll have
treasure in heaven
not to mention this life's a lot better
too but we have a special offer if
people want to know how to receive that
treasure especially during the time when
they're faced with physical economic
challenges
it's a classic pastor Doug a book
entitled riches of His grace amazing
facts that's been carrying this book for
a number of years and it's really
inspiring it's encouraging to read about
the plan of redemption and what God has
in store for those who love him if you'd
like to receive the book again it's
called the riches of His grace and the
number to call for that is our resource
phone line it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the book called the riches
of His grace that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and as
long as the the male is still working
which it is at this point we're gonna do
our very best to get this free offer to
you in the mail so just call and ask for
that again it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven if
you're in North America if you're
outside of North America we encourage
you to go to the website and amazing
facts dot o-r-g and you can read the
book for free on our library they're
amazing facts org we ready to go to the
phone lines right we've got dawn
listening in Florida dawn welcome to the
program hello hi thanks for waiting in
your call your question my question is I
once heard a pastor on the radio say
that Jesus never called his mother
mother but woman and that was because he
didn't want people mistakenly thinking
that she was the mother of God like they
do and
certain Christians sick they make her
out to be a deity what is your thought
on that well I would agree that it was
never the intention of God or Mary that
she should be treated as a deity there's
nothing in the scripture that says we
should pray to Mary or treat her as that
she's a saint above another church
member you know she was given a very
noble position she was no doubt a godly
woman we look forward to seeing her in
heaven but nothing in scripture says
that she should be exalted on the level
that some have put her where you pray to
statues or paintings of Mary or he you
know go through rituals Bible says we
approach God through Christ not through
any earthly family member now that woman
the word when Jesus says in John chapter
2 in John chapter 19 he refers to his
mother his woman that doesn't mean every
time he talked to her he said woman and
the word woman was not disrespectful you
know years ago when the hippie era when
I grew up if a motorcycle rider called
his his girlfriend woman it was sort of
degrading but that original word that
you find in John woman it means madam it
was a term of respect for a lady and he
may have used that in public when
addressing his mother but I'm sure it
only called her mom and I think also the
context the first time you read that is
John chapter 2 verse 4 Jesus was
approached by his mother and she asked
to help out in a situation where at the
wedding they had run out of wine and
grape juice and I think it was important
for Mary to understand that even though
Jesus was still her son she also needed
to recognize that he wasn't simply for
her service up to that point the last
thirty years Jesus was home taking care
of his mother taking care of the needs
of the family but the time had come for
him to do a much bigger work and I think
it was important for Mary also to
recognize that Jesus was not only her
son but she needed to be here to
understand that he was also a savior and
there was a transition that had to
occurs right so I think that's part of
the reason why Jesus says things the way
did hey thank you Dan oh I hope does
that make sense it it well it brings to
my
um a verse in Matthew 1250 I think we're
a disciple says hey Jesus your mother
and your brothers are outside they want
to see you and Jesus turns to his
disciples and says my mother brothers
and sisters are those who do the will of
my father in heaven mm-hmm so it seems
like he doesn't give her any special
status
I mean he's related to her but he loves
all women and men I mean he died on the
cross for us it just seems like that's
the priority he loves them the same yeah
absolutely and it's like a pastor Ross
was saying a minute ago he's reiterating
that even more important than any
genetic or earthly tie any biological
tie was doing the will of God what
really makes us the children of Abraham
is when we accept Christ and his
teachings and follow them
it wasn't anything a person can't say
well my dad was a pastor so I'm going to
heaven right or even Jesus brothers and
sisters couldn't say well you know I get
a pass because I've got a genetic tie no
you have to be doing the will of God
thanks so much that's a great question
done next one of the B heavies ginger
listening from Nebraska ginger welcome
to the program hello Pastor John and
Pastor dad good evening evening like my
question is Christian pertaining to
Isaiah 26 28 21 those verses have
anything to do with quarantine well let
me read them Isaiah you said chapter 26
verse 20 and 21 come my people and enter
into your chambers and shut your doors
behind you hide yourself as it were for
a little moment until the indignation is
passed for behold the Lord comes out of
his place to punish the inhabitants of
the earth for their iniquity for the
earth will also disclose her blood and
will no more cover her slain well it is
talking about taking shelter but it's
not talking about fallout shelter it's
not talking about sheltering at home
this is talking about he who hides in
the most high and I forget the exact
wording in Psalm 91 but it says the Lord
is our habitation
and though here we sing a song in our
church called the Lord is a shelter in a
time of need the Lord our rock and so
it's really talking about being
sheltered in Christ not inside a bunker
per se but it is interesting you know I
bet I'll get that question again because
it is an interesting verse that makes
you think kind of Harkins about what's
happening now everyone's kind of hiding
at home but most of all I think this
verse is talking about when it says
enter into the chambers and shut your
door it's talking about you know when
the the angel of judgment went through
the land of Egypt they had to be in a
home with the blood over the door and
they were protected from the plague in
the time of Rahab to survive the
destruction of Jericho they needed to be
in the house with this red rope that
represents the blood of Christ and the
best safety for people in our day is to
be in Christ and to be under the blood
as you say under the blood of the Lamb
but good question hey we appreciate that
very much
thanks so much you know it's also
interesting Jesus spoke about entering
into your chamber and closing the door
when it comes to prayer and I think if
ever there's a place of safety for the
believer now it is in communion with God
it's in prayer that's absolutely right
emphasizing that point you know we
probably ought to mention something just
in case people are wondering if if
California's got this shelter law what
are we doing here at the amazing fact
studios we ought to let people know that
we've got a very reduced crew operating
here tonight and the governor and the
laws of the state do allow for agencies
that operate media to continue operation
we have a greatly diminished crew but we
do operate three TV channels two in
Sacramento one national satellite
channel and they don't want media to
shut down so praise the Lord where at
least temporarily exempt we could say
we're trying to maintain our six feet
telling Karen maintain six feet but
she's not listening next caller there is
Tommy listening in Alabama Tommy walking
with the program thank you Pastor potato
yeah I know right now but as Christians
we're not to fear
anyway but when the body dies I just
wondered about the soul of the spirit
does it go to heaven or does it go to
the grave with the body well first we
got to answer what is spirit and the
word spirit you've got a course a Greek
word and a Hebrew word the word spirit
in Greek would be Numa and it simply
means breath or wind if you're a man I
bet you've used pneumatic tools before
those are tools that are driven by wind
by air and in the Old Testament the word
was Roth and it meant breath and so it's
simply saying that when a person dies
you can read this in Ecclesiastes 12 is
it verse 7 the spirit returns to God and
that means the breath returns to God
when anyone dies man-animal good bad
when someone dies the breath of life
returns to God the body returns to the
dust as it was until the resurrection
and at the resurrection God is going to
breathe that breath of life back into
these new glorified immortal bodies and
we will forever be with the Lord
so when a person dies excuse me if it
considered so late well it's not really
and people call it that but think about
it for a second Bible says to be absent
from the body is to be present with the
Lord
right so if you're a Christian and you
die your next conscious thought is the
resurrection so for you it's a moment
the twinkling of an eye it happens
almost instantaneous well god lives
outside of time so when our loved ones
die the next thing may know is the
resurrection but the resurrection hasn't
happened yet because the judgment and
the resurrection the Bible says is in
the last day the Bible say the living no
they'll die but the dead know not
anything that's Ecclesiastes chapter 9
so would it be okay if we send you we've
got a study guide that's got all these
verses in it and a lot more than we can
give you in two or three minutes that'd
be okay Tony yeah just call this
resource line we've got a great study
called are the dead really did the
number to call for that is 808 three
five six seven four seven and again you
can ask to the study called are the dead
really dead and we'll be able to send
that to you or anyone
calls and assets 883 five six seven four
seven as well as a website you got some
time on your hands perhaps you at home
you can look up the website death truth
calm death truth calm and there's a lot
of resources available even some video
content that you can look at some great
sermons great Bible studies on the
subject of what happens when a person
dies Harold is listening in Sacramento
Herald welcome to the program hi good
evening a pastor duck pastor Oz evening
hi well I'll meet my dad we uh we kind
of got into a little debate about it
what happens to Christians okay are we
being judged right now or will we be
judged after we die and as with with the
unrighteous with the wicked are they
being judged right now also or will they
be judged after they die
great question so first there are phases
of judgment we know that when the Lord
comes he's giving out rewards because
the Bible tells us judgment must begin
at the house of God and it says behold
he comes with the clouds his reward is
with him so if God is giving rewards
when he comes then at least some aspect
of the judgment takes place before he
comes to distinguish who is saved and
who is lost God knows who's saved and
who's lost when he comes because the
Bible tells us this two separate
resurrection so for God to know of
course God knows everything but for him
to demonstrate if you're in the first
resurrection of the second resurrection
some judgment has to take place before
he comes to determine if you're gonna
make it or not then there's a great
white throne judgment you can read about
in Revelation is a 22 yes thoughts in
chapter 20 yeah and you that is of
course in the future and then your final
the executive judgment where a
sentencing happens is at the end of the
1,000 years so we have a study guide
Herald we're glad you called with that
question because we have a study guide
that deals with the judgment that's
right the study guide is called case
closed the final judgment we'll be able
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks the number to call is we've given
earlier is a resource line that's 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and again just ask for the study guide
on the judgment it's called the final
judgment and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls an esque we've got
Frank listening in Alabama Frank welcome
to the program hi yes I was just
wondering you know with so many churches
not meeting physically right now of
course Christians need fellowship and
you know Christian education and things
like that
what would you recommend as far as
online churches or maybe even online
churches or some types of conference
calls maybe even that allow audience
participation do you have any ideas
about things like that cuz we sure need
something right now you know Frank I'm
so glad you asked that question it
pastor Ross and I were talking just
before the we went on the air and we
said we need to let people know how much
amazing facts is doing to provide on
loan online worship services and Bible
studies live ones and we're looking at
different ways that people can join us
even through technology like zoom where
you can actually see a little pictures
of the participants our pastors divided
up the phone numbers of members and I've
been making phone calls today and the
other pastors just praying with the
members so we've got to stay connected
but in some ways Frank I think that
what's happening now is a blessing
because for years a lot of Christians
have started thinking that the church
was the building and now when we can't
gather in the building they're realizing
the churches the people and we're
needing to stay connected praise God
we've got technology you know if this
was a hundred years ago it'd be
difficult but we've got telephones and
we've got cell phones and internet where
we should be checking in on each other
praying with each other and amazing fax
is streaming more and more programs
right now to minister to those that are
hunkered down in their homes you know we
have people that are sitting at home
over the weekend maybe you're looking
for some Bible study we do have a Bible
study that we pastor Doug and the rest
of the team here we actually livestream
a Bible study every Saturday morning at
10 o'clock which we doing during those
crisis and then also a worship service
at 11 o'clock so you
roughly tuned in and I believe pastor
daggits available well on Facebook on
YouTube you can go to the Granite Bay
Church website and you may see Zach make
amazing facts so trying to do everything
we can to communicate hope and
encouragement and the word even to folks
who at at home and I understand have we
started this this past weekend and even
the weekend before we've had some of a
record number of folks tuning in 250,000
people viewed the program two weeks ago
now after we broadcast it takes a few
days for right around its share and you
don't have to wait till Saturday or
Sunday to watch a good sermon I think
when people are in their homes they
ought to be doing all the studies that
they can but that's a great question
Frank we're really glad you called and
asked that amazing facts this is what we
do is we provide evangelistic devotional
Bible study material and we got an
archive also of not only these programs
but we've got probably hundreds of
sermons and youtubes that are online
from different evangelistic program
capacity you also released a little
facebook video clip about hoarding food
there's a lot of people out there lining
up with their grocery carts waiting for
the stores to open I and the shopping
like never before and you had this great
little I think it's available still on
Facebook yeah it's called hoarding food
how to order food for the storm for the
store I think we had like 500,000 views
at the various sites so a little bit of
a twist yeah people think I'm talking
about how to hoard food but it's really
storing away the Word of God and but
yeah we're gonna try and provide got a
new study I'd like to put out this week
on what we're learning prophetically
from this oh yeah pandemic very
important all right thanks for your Cola
Frank Nicks hold of the behaved is
listening from Tennessee
do we have later Lidia listening yes
Lida hi welcome to the program hi nice
to be here
my question is the chip consider the
mark of the beast and if not what would
be great question you know there have
been a lot of theories about what is
this mark in the hand or in the forehead
and for a while I remember when the
computer technology I'm old enough to
remember when they first started using
more computer technology and they had a
big computer in Brussels that was a
whole building and it's called the beast
and it was you know tracking some global
financial information and everyone said
that was the Beast of course now that
whole computer will probably fit in my
watch all the other technology that
computer and then for a while they said
that when the barcodes first came out
and they started putting barcodes and
all the products my friend said that's
the Beast don't buy anything that's got
a barcode on it and I think all those
friends starve to death years ago and
then no more recently they got the is it
called the RF D chips yeah that they put
you know they've put them for years
they've been putting them like under the
skin of dogs you can find a stray dog
and find his owner and his address and
now workers are putting them in
different organizations under their skin
there and they can actually be scanned
in and out of work and it tells what
when they get off the clock in it'll
clog out and folks are saying that's it
so others are doing it when they a
medical information so that there can be
a paramedic and they could just quickly
scan their chip and find out what's
their history and what are their needs
or what are their medicines and get a
little frightening all the information
that that's being gathered on every
individual they have so much on our
phones now if you've got a Google or
Facebook account there is so much
information they know where you are and
what you're buying that is not the mark
of the beast now let me tell you the
devil I think is going to use that
technology in the last days but if you
read in Deuteronomy chapter 6 after God
gives the Ten Commandments in
Deuteronomy chapter 5 chapter 6 he says
these words I command you today shall be
in your heart now we know that's a
symbol means in your affections not
physically in your heart and you shall
bind them for a sign on your hand and
they shall be frontlets between your
eyes three times in the law of Moses it
says on your hand in your forehead on
your hand in your forehead on your hand
in your forehead
where to have the law of God that means
in your actions in your thoughts in
Revelation at not only
that those who worship the Beast will
have the mark on their hand or in their
forehead
those who worship God will have the name
of God in their forehead well we don't
think that the churches are gonna put a
chip under the the eyebrows of people so
it's not a computer chip it's talking
about in the head in the forehead means
in the mind in the hand means in the
action it's gonna be seen in the worship
and in the behavior in the last days who
do they obey do they obey the laws of
the Beast or do they obey the laws of
God Leah if it's okay we have a study
guide that talks about the mark of the
beast and we want to send you a free
copy anyone that wants to know about
this you want to know what is the mark
of the beast especially in these days we
have a study that will make it clear
it's simply called the mark of the beast
is one of our amazing facts study guides
and we'd be happy to send this to anyone
who asks the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again just ask for that
study guide it's called the mark of the
beast very important subject you know
one of the most fearful warnings in all
of the Bible pass today is don't worship
the Beast don't receive his mark so it's
important for Christians to understand
this this teaching to know what is the
Beast what is the mark how to avoid it
yeah please get that free study the mark
of the beast now we're not going away
you hear the background music this is a
live program call in with your Bible
questions the best is yet to come
we'll be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273
your questions no I said that wrong
studio phone eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven and for the
free offer its eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven
I'm Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
we're gonna go back to the phone lines
we have Mariano listening Mariana
welcome to the program West Virginia I
believe yes thank you for and your
question comment in 2003 we started
visiting the church and a member length
of DVDs from your conference in 1999 oh
yes well praise the Lord now so going
you better answer your question your
phone feel it sounds like it's breaking
up yes yes Adam and Eve were created and
they were giving the in the Garden of
Eden with the Tree of Life but they were
to live forever but they still had the
Tree of Life and I just don't understand
why and they were going to fill the
earth God was going to put three of
lights'
recreate or something I don't know yeah
so if if they
had a gift of everlasting life then did
they need the tree the fruit to stay
alive is that what you're kind of
wondering yes that's my question
precisely yeah all right well let's see
what we can do
evidently you know when God first made
Adam and Eve he was given them bodies
that have the potential of living for
eternity but they were required to
continue eating from the tree of life
and because once God you know once they
sinned God said they were no longer able
to eat from the tree of life and now
their lives they would eventually age
and die but you didn't need to eat from
the tree very laufen often evidently
because Adam and Eve lived 900 while
Adam 930 years so in heaven the tree of
life will be there yes we are given the
gift of eternal life the Bible tells us
that there's a new kind of fruit on the
tree every month so I think we're gonna
be eating from that tree probably
monthly but yeah God gives us a gift of
everlasting life but we still have
bodies in heaven because it says we're
going to eat well plant vineyards we
will eat we will still drink when Jesus
rose from the dead he had a glorified
body but he said to the disciples do you
have anything to eat
so isn't that interesting that you know
people in heaven are not going to commit
suicide by starving themselves and so
yeah they've got eternal life but they
need to cooperate with God's divine laws
and one of them is you eat from the tree
at least once a month I suppose I don't
know mm-hmm and of course they gather in
the New Jerusalem to eat of the fruit of
the tree once a month because the Bible
says there's 12 different kinds of fruit
yeah so every month you go get a
different kind of fruit from the same
tree yeah like baskin-robbins 31 flavors
you go except it's got 144 flavors 12
different kinds of flavors 12 times a
year I'm not sure I can support that
from the Bible but anyway hey thanks so
much Mariano and good good to hear the
testimony about the net New York
meetings next caller the where is Ruth
listening from Georgia Ruth welcome to
the program hello pastor Doug and Pastor
John thank you for taking my call yes I
understand the symbolism when a sin
brought a lamb for a sin-offering in the
Old Testament it was to remind them of
Jesus the Lamb of God who would someday
come to forgive our sins well it has
come but what was the purpose or meaning
of multiple sacrifices of both brands
and lambs during certain Israelite
festivals such as referred to in numbers
29 verses 12 through 35 well I won't be
able to read verses 12 through 35 there
but you know all of the sacrifices in
one way or another talked about God's
having mercy on them as a nation and as
families and individuals a family might
bring if they were poor they might bring
a sacrifice of a dove I don't think
that's mentioned in this section but in
Leviticus it actually talks about
bringing turtledoves and then they might
bring a sheep or a goat they might bring
a a bowl the most expensive sacrifice
they could bring was usually a bowl in
oxen and when david brought the
tabernacle i'm sorry i brought the ark
up to jerusalem he'd walk six paces and
they'd sacrifice and when solomon
dedicated the temple it's almost
inconceivable they'd sacrifices the
houses to showing their their love and
their worship and sacrifice of god and
of course those sacrifices also served
to feed people during that time and
there were a lot of people in the in the
kingdom for the dedication so it wasn't
you know and it wasn't wasted butchering
that was going on but all the blood from
the various animals was all pointing to
cleansing from sin and atonement now I
am NOT a Hebrew scholar and so I'm sure
there's much more to this than we do
have a book that talks about the feast
days and what the meaning is of Christ
in the feast days so I think we've got a
fairly new book that deals with that
that you would probably really
appreciate and if you'd like to receive
that book I'm just looking
for the actual title pass that I gets
new you can just ask for the book on the
feast days yeah and I will be able to
send that to you Ruth or anyone the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
again just ask for the book on the feast
days it's a fairly new book that amazing
facts has I'll be able to send it to
anyone who calls and asks the next one
of the behave is listening from Toronto
Canada we have Jonathan who's on the
line Jonathan can you hear us
hi Jonathan how old are you five you're
five well bless your heart and what is
your question for us tonight
my question is why did Jesus die for us
oh that's a good question that's one of
the most important questions it's
because we've done things wrong we
disobeyed our Father in heaven and we
broke his law and there's a serious
punishment for hit breaking his law the
Bible says that it's a very dangerous
thing to break God's law because it
causes death but Jesus loves us and he
didn't want us to die he said I will die
for you it's kind of like if someone if
you do something wrong and your parents
have to punish you or spank you and
someone says no I want to take it for
you because I love you
Jesus took our punishment for us because
He loves us and that's why he had to die
on the cross because he wants us to say
but he rose from the dead he's alive in
heaven now and he wants us to be with
him in heaven too you know Jonathan we
have a series of lessons that amazing
facts geared for kids you might need to
have an older brother or sister help you
with it but it's called amazing
adventure and one of the lessons that we
have pass attack deals with this
important question why did Jesus have to
die so if you would have your parent go
to the amazing facts website and they'd
be able to find out how they can get the
Amazing Adventures set of lessons and
and you get an older brother or sister
if you have one or even your parents and
you guys go through those lessons I
think you'll really be blessed thanks
for your call Jonathan thanks for
listening all the way up there in
Toronto I might be one of our youngest
that's right we've got dawn listening in
Branson Florida hey Brandon dawn welcome
to the program
Edgar is that you are you there yeah
yeah yeah yeah and fell over call your
your question okay um thank you for
answering my question is the following
I believe I noticed a very important
prophecy in the Bible which can be
helpful to many people but I'm not
actually sure whether I can share that
information with others are not and the
reason of my hesitation is 2nd Peter 1
verse 20 which says knowing this first
that no prophecy of Scripture is of any
private interpretation could you please
interpret this first yeah we'll do our
best Thank You Edgar um you know if you
feel like God is giving you some
understanding on a prophecy that maybe
he's been neglect or some new light then
you should go and visit with people that
you think are well grounded in the Bible
when it says no private interpretation
you know we're we're a strengthened by
studying together and the Bible tells us
that the Berean Christians were noble
because they searched the word and they
did it together to see if these things
were so in the multitude of counselors
there is safety if one person comes up
and they said I've got new light nobody
else recognizes that it makes sense
biblically it may not be from the Lord
usually there'll be the mouth of two or
three witnesses that will say that is
sensible
it's biblically supported and so I'd
start by going to respected pastors or
elders in your church family and saying
the Lord has put this on my heart that
it may be some new light what do you
think I should do before I share that
does it make sense and I'd begin there
Edgar hey thank you for your call to
your question makes fun of a be have is
Kimberly listening from Louisville
Kentucky Kimberly welcome to the program
hi thank you both pastors yes I was just
wondering um with all the things that
are happen
in the world right now it just reminds
me possibly could we be entering the
little time of trouble great question
I heard someone else asked that question
and just for our friends out there that
are wondering what is Kimberly talking
about
everyone knows all Christians agree
there's a great time of trouble it's
called the tribulation revelation calls
it the seven last plagues and I love and
respect Christians on both sides of this
you know some believe that that's in the
past
some believe that that Time of Troubles
in the future some believe that great
time of trouble is gonna happen after
the second coming of Jesus or the
rapture some believe it happens rapture
happens in the middle of this time of
trouble and that there's a small time of
trouble before and then the great time
of trouble after I'm in the group that
believes that the time of trouble
happens before the second coming and
they're called the pre-trib do we
believe that the or rather we're
post-trib sorry we believe that the
Second Coming happens after the
tribulation yeah and that before the
Great Tribulation when the death decree
says people should be killed everyone
knows it says that in Revelation those
who do not worship the image of the
Beast should be killed it's very plain
no one can misunderstand that but before
that it says there's a time period when
they can't buy or sell and there'll be
some persecution and some pressure for
people to comply and some Christians may
have to head for the hills and and make
some pretty radical changes during that
time are we in that time now that's hard
to say but I don't think so because we
are going through a time of trouble keep
in mind there have been there was a
great time of trouble in the world world
war one world war two there was a
pandemic in the 1400s that took millions
of lives and Spanish flu shortly after
World War one so we are definitely in a
time of trouble are we in the small time
of trouble I don't think so because
during the small time of trouble there's
going to be religious persecution
I know churches are being told not
gather during this time but it's not
churches they're telling casinos not to
gather they're telling everybody doesn't
matter what denomination doesn't matter
if you're meeting Friday with the
Muslims Sabbath or Sunday
people are being told don't gather so I
don't think that this is the religious
persecution but I do think it is a time
of trouble there's definitely some
economic and medical fallout that's
gonna happen in connection with this
pandemic you know we do have a study
guide that specifically addresses some
of the things relating to the second
coming of Christ it's called the
ultimate deliverance it's one of our
more popular amazing vac study guides
what happens just before Jesus comes
what all the second coming of Christ be
like and the Bible has answers for that
and we'll be happy to send you that
study guide it's called the ultimate
deliverance and the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven as for the
study guide on the second coming of
Christ called the ultimate deliverance
thank you for your call Kimberly next
caller to be heavies isaac listening in
missouri isaac welcome to the program oh
thank you yeah thanks for calling my
question is about the rich young ruler
in Matthew 19 verses 16 and 17 it said
now behold one came and said to him good
teacher what good thing shall I do that
I may have eternal life so he said to
him why do you call me good no one is
good but one that is God but if you want
to enter into life keep the commandments
and so I'm I was kind of confused why
like Jesus said why do you call me good
no one is good the one that is God and
you know Jesus was Jesus saying he isn't
good yeah yeah that's a good question um
this is what I would I would call a
rhetorical question sometimes you ask a
question when you already know the
answer and you're trying to get someone
to think you know God says the Adam
where are you
well it wasn't cuz God had misplaced him
God sees everything you cannot flee from
his presence Jesus asked the disciples
what were you arguing about on the road
well he knew what they were arguing
about and now he's asking the
shirring ruler why do you call me good
there's no one really good but God do
you understand he's saying kind of in a
rhetorical way do you understand who
you're talking to if only God is good I
am the Messiah God the Son and so Christ
is kind of coming at the truth from a
different angle with him he's not
denying his goodness he's claiming his
godness see what we're saying okay yeah
okay so yeah and then you know Jesus
said if you would enter into life here's
what you need to do follow me well if he
wasn't good why would he say follow him
so he was acknowledging his goodness but
he was trying to get the young man to
see he wasn't just a rabbi he came to
him and said master rabbi that's the
term I think used in mark now he said
I'm not just the rabbi I want you to
know who I am so a good question I
appreciate that next color that we have
is Payton listening in Arizona Peyton
welcome to the program Arizona my
question my question is was there and
crowded Jesus baptism good question
Peyton thank you I think there was a
crowd there watching Jesus baptism
usually baptisms were done publicly kind
of like a wedding and when Jesus was
baptized John the Baptist said behold
now you would not invite people to look
at something if there's nobody there to
look and so John the Baptist said behold
the lamb of God that takes away the sin
of the world and I think in the Gospel
of John it tells us that was it Andrew
and I don't know if Angela Peter but
Andrew and John a couple of the
disciples were there and they saw that
and they went to Jesus after John the
Baptist said it so yes Jesus was
baptized publicly now maybe you're
afraid are you thinking of baptism and
you're worried about a crowd Peyton are
you are you wondering if there's going
to be a crowd at your baptism I'm
baptized
oh you are okay well good for you and
bless your heart all right well did that
answer your question
yes okay a appreciate that you'd also
you'll enjoy the amazing adventure study
that pastor Oz was talking about it's
kids it's made for kids from eight which
is how old you are to twelve perfect for
you let's go to the amazing facts
website maybe your parents can look it
up for you and search for the amazing
adventure set of lessons there's
actually a DVD set that goes along with
it
and I think you'd really enjoy that next
caller that we have is Schuyler
listening from looks like Kentucky
Schuyler welcome to the program hello
thank you so much both of you for
answering my question my question is if
I know of some people that are in fear
of what's going on right now and but I
also know that there is the beginning of
knowledge and I know that both of you
speak so much on that is the curfew in
lockdown implemented on on last Sabbath
to new jersey inside of their statement
of being at war with an invisible enemy
a foreshadow of the abomination of
desolation because the reason I asked is
because they said that the curfew was
set at 9:00 p.m. in respect to the
Sabbath meaning the Sunday Sabbath yeah
well that's interesting the and you know
there are so many Jewish people in New
Jersey in New York I think some of the
highest concentrations of Jewish
citizens I grew up in New York City and
my mom was Jewish is you know New York
New Jersey Brooklyn Miami and of course
Israel and so I'm surprised that they
said that but you know no I don't think
that this is specifically targeting like
I said any denomination they were
probably trying to respect the majority
of people in that community that do go
to church there's a very large Catholic
community in Christian community and I
think they're just trying to respect
their time but you know I do think we
are learning look how quickly civil
power
can be increased when there's a crisis
and Freedoms can be restricted and where
you go and when you go can be restricted
now fortunately we don't have I don't
have insane it in the news where there's
like sorry soldiers marching up and down
the streets ordering people under their
houses California's got one of the
strongest declarations and you know
people are still freely going to the
store and doing what they need to do so
it does it does kind of harken pictures
from Revelation and Daniel when you see
what's happening in the news it almost
seems apocalyptic
you know pastor Doug is so interesting
you see pictures even here in downtown
Sacramento typically a busy bustling
place and the streets are deserted
it's a strange yeah strange feeling yeah
and that's not something we see a Karen
and I were in China a couple times in
and when it first hit one an in
different cities people living there
sent out some pictures and we've got
some friends at work full-time in China
and and yeah whenever you're on the
street in China is just solid mass of
humanity and to see those big wide
streets empty and that was it was like
there's like a Hollywood movie you think
it is this for real so something is
going on friends old world is very
worried about a high death toll
connected with this pandemic and there's
gonna be an economic toll connected with
it to Mexico LA that we have is angry
listening from Colorado Andrew welcome
to the program hi guys hi thank you so
thanks thanks for taking my call I
wanted to just quickly ask I know we
don't have much time but what is the
difference between Seraphim and cherubim
well you've got the Seraphim that are by
the throne of God when you look in
Isaiah chapter 6 or is that that's right
those were the serifs and the cherubim
were on the ark that's rawson looking it
up you know as I get older he's gonna
have to look it up more often but
and when you say Serafim it is plural so
a cherub would be one cherub een is
plural meaning more than one I know that
they they said you've got cherubim on
the ark and when it talks about the
creatures in Isaiah chapter six by the
throne of God what is it is that the
Seraphim says they were Seraphim yes yes
that's Isaiah chapter six I'm not losing
my mind yeah six wings - wings they
cover their face - they cover their feet
and - they fly and there are other
references in Scripture but that's at
least one of them but yeah their God has
got different orders of creatures you
you read where it talks about there are
different principalities and powers and
even in the Angels good and evil there
are different levels of angels with
different responsibilities so and some
of that is a little mysterious I think
on the on the curtains of the sanctuary
the veil they also were embroidering
cherubim so these are the ministering
spirits it speaks of in Hebrews around
the throne of God
well thank you hope that helped a little
bit and we do you know we got a lesson
called message angel messages from space
talks about angels that's right it's one
of our study guides and we'll be happy
to send to anyone it's called three
angels messages actually angel messages
from space is the actual name of the
study guide the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can ask for that study
guide maybe time for one more pastor
that we've got there Marlin listening
from North Hollywood California okay I
get just a moment a minute what can we
do
yes I have a question my question is
that during the time of Samson when when
he was going to war with the Philistines
maybe when he got his eyes cut out who
was king during that era all right very
good question that is a trick question
as that was not during the era of the
kings it was during the era of the
judges and at the time when Solomon
Samson rather had his eyes plucked out
he was the judge it says he was the
judge of
Israel he judged Israel for 20 years and
so you know what's interesting there was
Sampson probably also lived during the
time of Ruth approximately so but he was
from one of the only judges I think from
the tribal but of Dan which was a little
further to the south and he evidently
lived too close to the Philistines Thank
You Marlon sorry to be so short with you
answer I hope it helped a little bit and
the listening friend we want to remind
you that we are in extraordinary times
as the founder of amazing facts used to
say we are marching off the map right
now that's what they call uncharted
waters but God is not surprised by any
of this I think in his word and in the
prophecies he for say he foresees what's
happening and this is a time for us to
especially be close to the Lord I think
it's a great time for us to all follow
the words of Jesus seek first the
kingdom of god in his righteousness make
that the priority coming to the Lord and
then going for the Lord we want to be
fully surrendered to Jesus and then
during that same time we want to be
witnesses for Christ we go and we share
now you may not be able to gather in big
groups in your church but that's why
amazing facts provides online worship
services every week we record these
services on Sabbath morning Saturday and
then many people use them again not only
through that day around the world but
then also on Sunday they're watching our
our Bible study and our worship services
we have a Tuesday evening Bible study
that streams from our location or even
the Granite Bay church website Granite
Bay Facebook page we want to stay in
touch with you just go to the amazing
facts page you'll find a lot more
information and archives or lessons
things to watch online while you're at
home amazing facts not orgy
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors in the last day prophecies such
as the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com can't get enough
amazing facts Bible study you don't have
to wait until next week to enjoy more
truth filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library at aft vor G
at aft vor G you can enjoy video and
audio presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vo
RG DT no amazing backs has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 257,000 that's one eight
forty four two one five seven thousand
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWE
study course and make sure to check out
our online bookstore at AF bookstore
calm which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]